[Music]
let's go to stevo steve in charleston
south carolina what's up steve
hello
hello
can you hear me i can can you hear me
i can how are you doing today
outstanding man
you're not from the southern united
states are you
what's that
you're not from the southern united
states are you
i'm not originally man you've picked it
up well done well done
i still talk like a texan i'm trying to
try to get it out of there hey so what's
up man how can i help
oh this is kind of the first time i'm
ever saying it out loud so just
bear with me for a minute um you got it
so in the beginning part of the
relationship between me and my current
wife i was unfaithful
and
at one point i ended up leaving because
i accepted
the fact that i was never gonna tell her
and i was just gonna hold it in and
and just
never break her with that and i just let
the guilt make me leave the relationship
later on down the line i made another
selfish act of coming back in
with the illusion that as long as i am
the man that i intend to be and plan to
be and want to be for her
um
that this could just be a dark secret
that gets hidden and
here we are years later and it's uh
eating away at me and
i've decided it's time that you know i
confess this to her regardless of which
way it goes
and i was just wondering some tips on
how i can best
convey this to her and support her
during this hard conversation
um
one thanks for saying it out loud man
thanks for saying out loud thank you um
i'm the first person you ever told that
uh yeah
wow
um
i'm reading around because you're [ __ ]
uh i started listening to you a few
weeks ago and uh
it started eating up and eating up and
firing up and firing up inside of me and
i i finally realized that i can't be who
i want to be
holding this secret in yeah and it's
also kept you from being the person
you've wanted to be all the time in the
past too right just find yourself here
yeah absolutely um i'm reading between
the lines here
um
did you cheat under where you were
dating too
like you you let you didn't leave your
marriage right
it was pretty much from
uh
the point where we started dating to
uh up until i left years ago
okay and when you say you left does that
mean you just broke up with her while
y'all were dating or you left your
marriage
marriage okay
um
how long have you all been married
uh
i mean since we're 18.
not super helpful because i don't know
how old you are now
oh uh sorry about uh seven eight years
okay
how many times have you cheated on her
eight years
uh
in the first
three
uh eight times and then never again
after that
so in the first three years was the same
person
no
tell me about people you're cheating
with
uh
i mean was it people you work with
girlfriends people from craigslist uh
people
that
on occasion that i went to high school
with
um
and then just random people you meet
over the internet
okay
what happened three years ago that you
said no more and you've gone five years
from
uh violating your marriage
uh i realized that
you know those actions were
part of a
were being selfish of me and just kind
of feeding into a selfish behavior that
i've had for a while and
i didn't enjoy it i didn't enjoy
being selfish every bit of it came with
guilt but i couldn't seem to
keep myself on the straight path and
the illusion of not seeing not ever
having this girl again and
losing the opportunity to have a family
with her uh
it kind of just
made me think that i can hide this
secret and continue on the straight and
narrow and it would be like it never was
and never happened so here i am
we'll get to how do you tell
okay there's an important there's an
important way to do that the right way
to do that and there's a couple of
terrible wrong ways to do it
here's my concern
your reason for quitting
cheating on your wife
is still utterly selfish
you have not you've you don't want to
blow this with her
you want to have a family with her you
want to stop feeling guilty
and when i haven't heard from you is
i destroyed the life of somebody that i
love
and there's an
empathy
there's a submission there's a take in a
knee
while somebody sits above you
and saying i'm sorry because i've just
thrown a grenade in everything you think
you know
and i don't hear that in you
i may have i mean maybe it's
the first time i'm saying it because
that's what's in my mind okay
uh
that's why you know it hasn't occurred
again and that's why i've gotten to the
point of feeling
as if i need to confess about this
because
i i mean everything we've built and the
person that she thinks she's with is is
wrapped around an entire lie that
would change
everything from
you know our whole entire relationship
okay
so here's here's kind of the mechanics
moving forward okay i want you to think
of this um
the the way i was trained to do death
notifications by dr andy young this
guy's
a super important man to me uh brilliant
man
gave me the line facts are your friends
when you're having hard conversations
i've also been a part of having to let
employees go um having to tell people
that their kids have passed away like
like my whole career has been hard
conversations and i did it wrong for a
long time
and
until dr young gave me some pretty clear
guidance so i'm going to pass that
guidance from him through me on to you
okay
what's about to happen
is the death of her life
okay
you're about to put a period at the end
of everything she thinks she knows and
there'll be a before and after in her
life okay why am i telling you that i
want you to treat it that way
and when you treat it that way facts are
your friends
so here's what that means
talk way less than you think you need to
the moment you sit down and say this is
a heavy conversation her heart's going
to start beating fast and she's going to
have some idea because you did leave at
some point right
yes
um is there any chance she knows about
this and has chosen to not think about
it
uh
i think so i feel as if there's not 100
trust there
and we're kind of just in a charade yeah
she pretends to believe me um
because when i came back she you know
she hasn't had any inklings so she chose
kind of the
forget the past but that doesn't also
give me her full trust
a lot of times people will yeah
completely undeserving and well in the
same way that you buried part of your
life she's buried part of hers so that
we can maintain and just keep heading
forward
right and we think that if we uncover
this it's going to be worse and what you
find out over time is no the longer that
secret stays buried the more those
secrets are become infected right
and then it becomes less about you
cheated on me which is huge
you cheated me multiple times
you made me unsafe you slept with people
off the internet and made me unsafe
to
was
christmas even real was thanksgiving
right so it it it begins to erode
everything right
so yeah um talk way less than you think
be very specific and very clear what i
mean by that
um
not
um i just
there were some times when i experienced
unfaithfulness no
when we were dating on seven different
occasions i cheated on you i had sex
with other people
then we were married the first three
years of our marriage i had sex with
eight different people
or i had sex with four different people
two times each
i have not slept with anybody else i've
not cheated on you either physically or
emotionally in eight years i mean five
years
you see what i'm saying that's specific
and then there's a period at the end of
that sentence
not and i know it's going to break your
heart and because here's the thing all
that explaining all of the
she is going to be in full fight or
flight
her ability to process and rationally
think through and let's talk
that will be over it will be about
survival
okay
so that's number one
um number two
do
not
lie
till all of the truth
okay if we're gonna go there let's let's
just go there is there a chance that any
of these people were her friends or
something that's gonna be even more
explosive on top of the already
explosive
no uh
just
nope
okay
um
okay so don't lie and number three
here's what i did
here's what i'm doing
and i'm at your mercy now
okay she gets to speak into what healing
will look like if there's going to be
healing
okay
so here's what i did i cheated on you
period here's what i'm doing now haven't
done anything for five years i don't
have facebook anymore i deleted
instagram because i'm not talking to
people on the internet here's the steps
i've taken
and i number three i know i've hurt you
deeply
and
i know it's gonna take time for us to
heal
and what i can tell you is i'm sorry and
i'm willing to do whatever it takes
that's the last thing i'm gonna say
okay and she might say why what happened
what was going on
i think it's important in that moment to
say
i want to stay in this conversation and
not go back yet
i'm sorry i violated our marriage i'm
sorry you deserved better than that and
i'm sorry
and i've made steps that it will never
happen again but i know i've got a long
way to go i want you to keep bringing it
back to the present back to the
president back to the present okay
okay
here's the last thing i'll tell you
um
i i i say we're in the john wick
generation
of people who watch a lot of movies and
they're like if dude if that ever
happened to me you know what i would do
and i always laugh and i'm like you have
no idea what you would do
all right like if that bad guy came in
here and started shooting you know what
i would do you would probably 98 of the
world would duck and run and that's not
a bad thing you would duck a run right
um
you you have no idea what her response
will be even though you have played it
out in your head
and i want you to be at peace with the
immediate reaction and then understand
this is gonna unfold for a while okay
what that means is this she might say
get out
get out
and
i think the wise thing to do would be to
stand up and say i love you i'm sorry
maybe you have a letter written and you
put it right down there and then you
leave
okay
she may want to talk and talk and talk
and talk i think that's not super wise
but also some people just process that
way like i said keep bringing it back to
the present back to the present back to
the present
if you take a break let's take a 30
minute break let's take an hour break
and then we can talk about the past um
that might be a wise thing to do and
then you can kind of talk start talking
about other things but
she may tell you to get out and she may
file for divorce monday
and she may tell you to get out and she
doesn't want to talk to you she won't
return your text won't turn your calls
and then she'll call you back in a week
or she may say
man steve i knew this i knew
i knew
and now you'll have some healing to
begin
right or she may say i'm not leaving you
you're not getting rid of me but we've
got a lot right you see what i'm saying
you have no idea what the response is
gonna be even though you think you know
it's gonna be are you at peace with that
i
yeah
uh no but yeah um that's a good answer
actually yeah it's a great answer it's
something that i've accepted that i will
have to deal with you know because it's
the consequence of my actions um
so yes and now dude that's some that's
some brave ownership there where'd you
learn that because that's new for you
just
uh
i mean a lot of it probably came from
listen to these last few weeks and
really reflecting back on my life um
and realizing a lot of the hurtful
things that i've done that
you know i can't can't take back but can
own up to him now and move forward being
the person that i want to be it's
awesome i mean that literally is the
only step you got right is to own what
happened and then move on
um
do not
don't don't don't don't please i'm
smiling right now don't do this
don't say hey i've been listening to
this podcast for the last few weeks and
i realized i need to tell you something
because what that will do is that will
diminish the last eight years of
deception into
well this guy i listened to told right
um
this will be and remember what i said
earlier the more you talk about you
and what you've been experiencing
it diminishes the
apology it diminishes this moment
because this moment's going to be about
her
right this this coming clean is going to
be about her you're going to benefit
from it right you're going to walk
taller and you're going to sleep deeper
than you have in a while but you might
be doing it on a friend's couch um are
you prepared for her just to say get out
and file for divorce
uh
it terrifies me but
of course you know i it's a possibility
that like i said i just
have to accept is
a possibility
what do you think she's gonna say
i don't know um
i have two versions
in my mind the
the
you know like you said i knew
i didn't fully know but i know now
and you know how do we move forward
and then the other is that's your
fantasy response right
yeah
and then the more realism comes down to
you
you know maybe not kicking me out but
we need to figure out you know what the
next steps are for this to end
i just you have this like fantasy she's
like
go get some beers and some enchiladas
and we're going to talk about this and
we'll figure it out right right probably
not hey blue's got a dream
yes
um
uh
i'll tell you this what you did was
stupid and it was selfish and it was
hurtful and you know that right i agree
yes sir um what you're doing now is
brave and honest and you're heading off
into uncharted water
and um so i'm not gonna applaud you for
what you did but i'm gonna applaud you
for what you're doing okay
uh sir that's a brave i'm proud of you
i've come to believe over the last five
or six years especially last three or
four in my own marriage
secrets kill they destroy everything and
then as i've looked at the physiology
and biology of secrets they're so
destructive
and so i think you're wise i think
you're wise for your personal health
your relationship if your marriage and
most importantly for that sweet woman
that you're married to
um
also dude i make no illusions about
relationships have two peop two players
okay
the time for yeah but you and that will
come in counseling on the back end of
this okay
this will be about you taking ownership
of what you've done um have you read my
new book
i have not okay hang on the line i'll
send you a free copy okay
and
ironically the name of the book is own
your past change your future and that's
you right
yes sir like here's where we are and i
gotta own what happened and then we
gotta make some plans for moving forward
um will you do me a favor and reach out
to me when this when when and let me
know how it goes
yes sir i will okay um i you know what
i'm thinking here as i'm about to hang
up here but
i think it would be wise to hand write a
letter and put it in an envelope and
seal it
and um
give it to her
because she's going to go into fight or
flight when you tell her this stuff
and
um
when people did the letter b
just like just
basically what i would be saying to her
out loud no this is the letter is more i
love you and i screwed up
it's going to be less specific you don't
need to say in the letter i i did i had
sex with eight different people you
don't just say that
say i understand that hurt you deeply
and i understand that you're gonna feel
like you're crazy and you're gonna feel
like the last eight years of your life
have been a lie the last 10 or 12 years
of your life have been a lie
and while it all hasn't been a lie i do
understand it
and that you'll go to your grave
heartbroken that you broke her heart
and you're asking for forgiveness and
you're willing to do what it takes to
move forward together
okay
but there's something tangible about it
and that way she can feel it and see it
and read it again and read it again and
read it again it won't be an excuse
thing it won't be uh
well i just did this none of that it's
gonna take full ownership but it's
letting her know i love you and
i'm willing to do what it takes to move
forward are you willing to do what it
takes i don't put words in your mouth
yes sir okay that's that's what i hear
that in your voice um brother i'm proud
of you and you got some hard hard hard
uh
steps to take
and it's gonna get way worse before it
gets better um but i'm proud of you and
you're doing the right thing you're
doing the right thing
holler back at me let me know how this
conversation goes and we will be
thinking about you talk way less than
you think fax or your friends do not lie
ask her how you can participate in her
healing if she'll have you
and be prepared for this thing to get
way off the rails way off the rails